my name is Marsha Tate I'm a resource
specialist with Los Angeles Unified
School District many people don't know
my name they just called me gutsy
I love berkshire hathaway stands for i
diversified the companies that they have
invested in i set a goal out to become a
shareholder by the time I was 40 years
old two or three o'clock in the morning
I just decide hey I'm just gonna write
Warren Buffett I just asked him you know
would he ever submit nine shareholders
to attend his meeting I thought it first
it was junk mail I was screaming because
I almost tore it in half like there's
like I was like ah he actually wrote me
back almost immediately he told me the
letter to contact his assistant debbie
personick we were gonna meet at a mutual
place because he was going to be
attending this party when it comes over
to me you know I said thank you so much
for allowing me to be here already
it's just been an amazing experience and
he says why just hope you get what you
were looking for it's all about meeting
great people just like yourself you know
he was paying me a compliment and I said
oh what a great goodbye many of the
vendors are there from all the
subsidiaries in which Berkshire owns
there would be breach tournaments you
would see Warren and Bill Gates playing
bridge I mean it's just so many
different things that you see and learn
I called my stockbroker and I said I've
gotta become a shareholder as soon as
the market open you know just buy me up
whenever you know I can't write down so
I get home Warren made me feel respected
and like I was worthy to be there as
well as worthy to be acknowledged as you
know an educated that's to me is it's
just awesome